aujourd'hui instruction player vs games
le jeu
c'est comme si c'était un film et que le
jeu est sorti tapez apprécié la blague
aaa et à l'un de nous deux en fait qui
joue le père qui doit aller au bout du
niveau et l'autre qui déclenche tous les
pièges qui fait même apparaître des
monstres seipati l'ol un nazi mika
honneur la toile moi je fais par exemple
faire apparaître montre aux gens une
créature comme ça voilà possible faire
en sorte à la gamme est en pause le jeu
par exemple héros et est retournée
légaux retourner l'écran c'est plus
correct mais nathan quoi avec des
formateurs du bois rien là a tempéré
il y avait mon train voilà de quoi j'ai
quatre pièces gp a expliqué du tout je
suis avec des pelles finalement par
contre profite pas que du fait que
j'explique parce que sinon voilà de quoi
j'ai quatrième je peux faire apparaître
mon se met en pause le jeu faire en
sorte qu'ils hague et retourner l'écran
voilà donc c'est vraiment amusant c'est
vrai que ça qu on peut aller il est trop
le malin et aux hommages à l'étape 3 du
code tension continue mais non mais j'ai
bien pu y avait même pas de piège les
cibles ayem elle voyage
c'est quoi le piège d'un [ __ ] ya un
piège invisible il faut il encore du
ramage une pièce et que tu la mettes
là-dedans bah voilà on du côté du nom tu
as gagné tu as fait bugger le pc windows
xp bas c'est les mecs ils font des
blagues mais c'est un windows xp
toujours donc là on va faire level 2
attend les pays sont nulles quoi ça fait
chier personne et pièges comme ça
attends attends nouveau piège au hockey
attention alors cela je vais bien me
s'effectue de tête
voilà était beau et c'est quoi dans la
vie on dit que voilà on dit aux mecs
quoi on allait monter à rien
or madrid un monstre mais j'ai du mal du
malin bien moi oh mais ballon vers le
haut elle est belle île à la pièce est
là maintenant il faut qu'ils
redescendent jeu spam les pièges
enfin parce que je me dis oui on était
morts et au millimètre du pzero gales
attend parce qu'en fait j'ai un petit
piège bonus voilà
et oui parce que je n'avais pas prévenu
mika mais en activant donc tous les
pièges beaucoup de fois j'ai un piège
bonus à les accès les allées là c'est
chaud c'est drôle à kaunas attendaient
je peux jouer et on parle même bar est
attendu c'est moi je vais tomber dans le
vide at-on piel non arrêtons piège d'un
éveil images d'un combo de la mort
y'avait jersey on voulait dire dans
cette partie homi k os x et leurs
excellences complète en soit j'aime ce
que je fais mais soit pas d'aix pas ce
que je vais trouver le comptoir garde
toute vitesse dans ce pays
trop de morts dans ce pays
connard connard aux copains et c'est
pourquoi ce que moi je suis fort au jeu
ou qui demandent du style et vu que ça
ça demande pas de ce qu'il a vu et
mallet soient fiers à bras du coup je
vais annuler sa ce piège et se soucier
marouf say say say say say say we check
polt s'est raté au pas loin connard va
et c'est gagné
arrête un pied sur cette touche mais tu
as perdu la nanon level 2 celui-là il
est dû en afrique aux eaux
jean-michel esquive je peux patiner wes
airbags et alors et alors vers h pas car
ça s'est passé juste à galérer andrassy
les galères et comme toi regardez les
deux les deux plus grands traits à
l'heure de france réuni à temps mais
c'est extrêmement simple à rennes
et pour de vrai parce qu'on a pas
expliqué au journal explique aux gens la
bête a touché rose a fait ça et pour
commencer niveau sorte alors que ça veut
dire qu'elle est fière des fois ça peut
pas être la nature
du coup je suis triste pour toi je me
cache pas qu'on a au nom de la source
qu'il quittait s'inverse à nos juniors a
chuté à l'onu je suis revenu sur
l'éthique la [ __ ] aux allées au nom
c'est la non la la comme angers
recherche what you're gone a tous une
[ __ ]
hadorn afghane azadi un enfant on a 12
ans à 13.7 de personnes ont regardé les
steppers mellado ça vous a plu
que tout le monde n'avait fait pas comme
ça qu'on des rois pis